we are going to destroy the night king
and his army people do it together
you have my word and your family hasn't
seen its end you're still here I can't
have children who told you that there
weren't you murdered my husband has it
occurred to you she might not have been
a reliable source of information
hey everybody so there's a bunch of Game
of Thrones that's been dropping this
week and a lot of you requested a new
Daenerys Jon Snow video so this will be
a little bit about endgame as it applies
to their characters in the future of
House Targaryen because there are all
kinds of theories about the way the show
weaves the metaphors of azor Ahai if
there's going to be a Nissa Nissa which
main characters are gonna have to die in
order to fulfill martin's promise of a
bittersweet ending so if you're finding
me for the first time I do weekly Game
of Thrones be sure to subscribe to get
everything
they'll be giveaway stuff at the end of
the video - so isn't it so nice like I
the reason I included those clips at the
beginning is because they're basically
narrating exactly what they're going to
be doing in season 8 isn't it so nice
when characters tell you exactly what
they're gonna do there really hasn't
been any question about their fight
against the night king obviously they're
marshaling all their forces at
Winterfell
the real questions are what's the future
of Daenerys family like she talks about
the dragons dying out because they were
caged so she's trying to break the wheel
so there's a lot of metaphors about them
trying to stop the cycle of Ice and Fire
trying to get rid of the Nike as well as
trying to end the game of Thrones that's
really the wheel that she was trying to
break when she was first coming to
Westeros during season seven she didn't
know anything about the night King at
that point didn't know anything about
prophecies even though Kim vara did
visit Varys way back during season six
because of the way the show jumps
forward in time we don't even know if
Varys ever told her about that we got a
visit from this mysterious High
Priestess from the red temples she says
some really creepy [ __ ] that involves
you and things are much bigger than we
ever thought before I think the way they
reacted to Melisandre is talked about
prophecy Varys did not have that
conversation with her part of the idea
of season seven is that it took Jon Snow
showing her those cave paintings I know
there were all kinds of jokes about that
and then her actually seeing the night
king up north of the wall before she
really believed what everyone was
talking about there's a little bit of
misdirection coming with this wind says
plot brans going to drop the bomb that
Jon Snow is secretly a Targaryen
he's Aegon he's the rightful heir to the
Iron Throne that all seems like it's
just meant to keep you busy thinking
about how the characters are going to
stay together long enough to fight the
night king while he's on his way so even
though I'm
% on board with George RR Martin's
bittersweet ending and most of the main
characters dying I still think that it's
an optimistic story they'll come
together I think most people believe
that too it's just a question of which
characters survived to the end so they
defeat the night king but as Daenerys
talks about her family dying out I can't
have children this is the end the
Targaryens aren't special people in
John's trying to talk her down off that
ledge you're still here maybe the witch
that killed your child and husband isn't
a totally reliable source of information
just seems like it's building towards
the future of a House Targaryen even if
Jon Snow and Daenerys aren't both around
to enjoy that so a big part of the end
of the story is the idea that azor Ahai
will rise and kill the night king but a
lot of you have asked me throughout the
season about the Nissa Nissa of it all
so if you don't know who Nissa Nissa is
one of the really important parts of the
azure 'hi myth is that he had to forge
the light bringer sort it in order to do
that he had to temper the sword in the
sole of his Nissa Nissa his wife his
beloved so i'll read part of this myth
here so he tries a couple different
times to forge the blade but the blade
keeps cracking because he hasn't
tempered it the right way the third time
with a heavy heart for he knew
beforehand what he must do to finish the
blade light bringer he worked for a
hundred days and nights until it was
finished this time he called for his
wife Nissa Nissa in asked her to bare
her breast he drove his sword into her
breast her soul combining with the steel
of the sword creating light bringer
while her cry of anguish and ecstasy led
a crack across the face of the moon
that's taken out of a Davos chapter in
book three so it's taken right out of
Martin's main novels so people have
taken this literally meaning that Jon
Snow or whoever you think as or hayas
would have to plunge his sword into the
breast of whoever their beloved is so in
the case of Jon Snow thats Daenerys now
so the important thing is Melisandre
says prophecy is a tricky thing I think
it's more of a metaphor and when you
talk about the soul combining with
Lightbringer the idea that Lightbringer
is a number of different things on the
show yes Longclaw is a version of lie
Springer but the dragons are also a
version of Lightbringer and sort of tied
up in the idea of the future of house
targaryen in this mystery about whether
or not Daenerys can really have more
children is that her child will also be
Lightbringer
so like part of her soul would combine
with Jon Snow they would make a baby
that baby would be Lightbringer but
obviously the reason why you have to
take the idea of a Zora high and light
bringers more of a metaphor is is
because it's not like she's gonna give
birth to a baby and then that baby will
immediately kill the night king because
a lot of people take it in a really
literal context which i think is
probably a mistake and that somebody
will have a literal light bringer he'll
push it right through the night king and
that'll be the end of it but just
remember the way the TV show weaves
metaphors so the idea that you know not
all of them are gonna survive and I
definitely think that Jon Snow and
Daenerys won't both survive but I do
believe that she will get pregnant with
a baby that baby will be the future of
House Targaryen so like they're talking
about how her house is not ended when
they're picking up the baby dragon bones
so there will be a future of House
Targaryen
they're sort of the Skywalker's of the
Game of Thrones series there's even the
idea that one or more of the prequel
series is centered around Targaryen
things in the past so they're just so
big in the game of Thrones series it's
not like this is going to be the
ultimate end of their family but if you
do want to believe that Jon Snow is
going to survive Daenerys will die I
still believe that they will have a
child that child will survive so even in
that scenario where Jon Snow to continue
living he would be the future of House
Targaryen but he's not going to take the
Targaryen name he's still going to
consider himself a start in Ned Stark
his true father but in the very simplest
of terms you see what the show has been
foreshadowing that this is not the end
of their family there will be future
Targaryens even if not everybody is
alive to see it so let me know in the
comments what do you think about the
idea of the Nissa Nissa azor Ahai myth
as it applies to the metaphors of the TV
show like not in a literal context not
someone literally plunging their sword
into someone else's breasts but the
funny thing about this show you know
funny twist is that while it mostly
trades in metaphors for the really big
stuff it does do a lot of
i winking with literal fulfillments of
foreshadowing moments like that so I do
believe there will be a moment where
somebody plunges their sword into their
beloved's breasts but I think that's
more of a Cersei type thing and I know a
lot of you are asking about the Jaime
azor Ahai idea so I am planning on doing
a video about that sometime soon but
leave all your bonus video requests in
the comments below and real big question
for you guys in the comments star trek
discovery is premiering this Sunday do
you guys want me to do videos for that I
will do a non-spoilery review
so that'll post tomorrow but just think
about that in the back of your mind
until I post that video so there is a
new round of that HBO now giveaway I'll
just announce a winner the next time I
post game of thrones that'll be on
Sunday so while you wait for everything
you can click here to learn more about
Aegon Targaryen and you can click here
to watch that Targaryen animated prequel
again to thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight